what's the difference between violence
on the individual level versus group
is um it seems like with chimps and with
wolves there's something about
the dynamic of multiple
chimps together
that increase the chance of violence or
is is violence still
fundamentally part of the individual
like would would an individual be
as violent as they might be as part of a
group
if we're talking about uh killing
okay then um
violence in the sense of killing is very
much associated with
a group
and the reason is
that individuals
don't benefit by getting into a fight in
which they risk being hurt themselves
so it's only when you have overwhelming
power
that the temptation to try and kill
another victim
rises
sufficiently for them to be motivated to
do it
the
the average
number of chimpanzee males that attack a
single male
in uh something like 50 observations
that have accumulated in the last 50
years
from various different study sites
is eight
eight to one now sometimes it can go as
low as uh three to one
but that's a that's getting risky
but if you have eight you can see what
can happen i mean basically uh
you have one male on one foot another
male another foot another male and an
arm another male another arm
now you have an immobilized victim
with uh four individuals capable of just
doing the damage and so they can then
move in and tear out his thorax and tear
off his testicles and and twist an arm
until it breaks and uh and do this you
know appalling damage with no weapons
what is uh
the way in which they prefer
to commit the violence is there
something to be said about like the
actual
process of it is there an artistry to it
so if you look at human
warfare
there's different parts in history
prefer different kind of approaches to
violence it had more to do with tools i
think on the human side
but
just the nature of violence itself
sorry the practice the strategy of
violence is it basically the same you
improvise you immobilize the uh
the victim
and they just rip off different parts of
their body kind of thing
yeah you have to understand that uh
these things are happening at high speed
um in thick vegetation yes mostly so
that they
they have not been filmed uh carefully
you know we we have a few
little glimpses of them from
uh one or two people like david watts so
who's got some great video but
we don't know enough to be able to to
say that it's hard for me to imagine
that there are styles that vary between
um communities you know cultural styles
but
it is possible and one thing that is
striking is that the number of times
that an individual victim has been
killed immediately
uh has been higher in
kibali forest in uganda
than in in gombe national park in
tanzania it's conceivable that's just
chance we don't have real numbers now
but
what is this um i can't remember exact
numbers but you know 10 versus uh 15 or
something um
so so maybe
they
damage to the point of
uh expecting a death in one place and
they just finish it off in the other but
most likely
that sort of difference will be due to
differences in the numbers of
attackers
you know human beings are able to
conceive of the philosophical notion of
death of mortality
is there any of that
for chimps
when they're thinking about violence is
violence like what what is the nature
of their conception of violence do you
think
do they do they realize they're taking
another conscious being's
life or is it some kind of
like optimization over the use of
resources or something like that
i i don't think it's i can't think of
any way to get an answer to the question
of what they know about that um i think
that
the way to think about
the motivation
is
rather like
the motivation in sex
so when males are
interested in having sex with a female
whether it's in chimpanzees or in humans
they don't think about the fact that
what this is going to do is to lead to a
baby
mostly
you're right mostly what they're
thinking about is i want to get my
underway
uh and um i think that that's a similar
kind of process uh with the gems you
know what they are thinking about is
i i want to kill this yes it's
individual
and it's hard to imagine that uh
taking the other individual's
perspective and thinking about what it
means for them to die is going to be an
important part of that in fact you know
there's reasons to think it should not
be an important part of it because it
might inhibit them and they don't want
to be inhibited you know the more
efficient they are in doing this the
better but you know i think it's
interesting to think about this whole
motivational question because it does
um produced as a rather haunting thought
that there has been selection in favor
of
enthusiasm about killing
and in our
relatively gentle and uh you know
deliberately moral society that we have
today
it's very difficult for us to face the
thought that uh in
all of us
there might have been
a re residue and a more than that sort
of an actively uh an active potential
for that thought of me really enjoying
killing someone else
but
i i think you know one can sustain that
thought fairly obviously by
thinking of circumstances in which
it would be true
that the ordinary
human male
would be delighted to be part of a group
that was killing someone what you've got
to do is to
be in a position where you're regarding
the victim as dangerous
and
thoroughly hostile
but the pure enjoyment of violence
there's uh i don't know if you know this
historian dan carlin he has a podcast
he has an episode
three four hour
episode that i recommend to others it's
quite haunting
but he takes us through an entire
history uh it's called painfultainment
the uh the history of
humans
enjoying the murder of others in a large
group so like public executions were
part of long part of human history and
there's something that um
for some reason humans seem to have been
drawn
to just watching others die
and he ventures to say that that may
still be part of us for example he said
if it was possible to televise
to stream online for example the
execution and the murder of somebody or
even the torture of somebody
that
uh a very large fraction of
the population on earth would not be
able to look away they'd be drawn to
that somehow as a very dark
thought
that we were drawn to that
so you think that's part of us in there
somewhere that selection that we evolved
for the enjoyment of killing and the
enjoyment of observing
uh
those in our tribe
doing the killing
yes i mean and that word you produced at
the end is critical i think you know
because
it would be a little bit weird i think
uh to
imagine
a lot of enjoyment about
people in your own tribe being killed
right yeah i i don't think we're
interested in violence for violence's
sake that much
um it's um
it's when you get these social
boundaries set up
and
in today's world
you know happily
uh
we
kind of are already one world
you know we
you have to dehumanize someone to get to
the point where they are really outside
you know our recognition of a tribe at
some level which is you know the whole
human species
but in
ancient times that would not have been
true because in ancient times
there are lots of accounts of hunters
and gatherers
in which
the appearance of a stranger
would lead to
an immediate response of
shooting on site
because what was human was the people
that were in your society
and the
other things that actually looked like
us and you know were human in that sense
were not regarded as human
so there was a kind of automatic
dehumanization of everybody that didn't
speak our language or hadn't already
somehow
recognized as uh
sufficiently like us to escape the the
dehumanization context and so hopefully
the story of human history is that we
are
that tribalism fades away
that our
dehumanization the natural desire to
dehumanize our tendency to dehumanize
groups that are not within this tribe
decreases over time and so then
the desire for violence decreases over
time yeah i mean that that's the
optimistic perspective and uh and the
the great sort of concern of course is
that
um small conflicts can build up into
bigger conflicts and then dehumanization
happens and then violence is released
as hannah aaron says you know there
currently is no uh known alternative to
war as a means of settling really
important conflicts
you